come to this story here I saw this tweet
and I'm just I'm just assuming it's true
I don't know when it's it's posted today
Florida state senator what is this at
Governor gone wild who's this Blaze uh
ingoglia floor Senator uh past chairman
of Florida GOP files a bill to decertify
any political party whose platform ever
supported slavery the bill is titled the
ultimate cancel act mic drop uh I agree
all in favor of I thought mic drop was
in the name of the app all in favor of
decertifying any political party who
ever supported slavery say aye here here
Tim hi hi all right well okay let's go
through the list of uh major political
parties and see which ones are stricken
we have Republicans uh they're good and
then we have Democrats and yeah they're
they're they're out and uh that's the
list okay all right the green party is
like Here We Come This Is Us
everyone moves over that's a chance I I
agree with this bill actually 100 and it
should if they're gonna go tear down
statues then uh yeah let's get rid of
the Democratic Party
there we go I like that in most public
high schools in America they'll teach
you oh well actually it was Republicans
it's just that the parties change names
or some like they twist the logic so
intensely to make it be like well what
it couldn't be Democrats Democrats would
never I mean there are still people
alive today who are who are Democrats
and clan members but you know that's
besides the point
no no they don't acknowledge still alive
today yeah yeah
how long ago was it where uh uh I mean
this was like the 60s 70s I mean there's
the clan still exists yes many of these
people probably are no longer democrats
for sure I mean but you'd be surprised
there there have been white nationalists
have come out and talked about how the
Democratic platform is good and then
they explain all the things that
typically Republicans complain about
like like the Democrats destroying the
black family and things like that
so yeah do you get it didn't Richard
Spencer endorse yeah Richard Spencer is
a big biting guy right now he was too I
think in uh 2020 he was for by not Trump
yeah he says because Trump didn't do the
things they thought he was going to do
he wasn't that guy anybody that's for
physical removal is got there there's
got to be a big government to go along
to do the removing like anybody that's
talked like Spencer was used to be Pro
you know removing people and stuff he
likes Authority yeah so does the
Democratic party yeah you you don't get
it I'm just look I don't know about all
that I'm just saying antifa went around
and BLM went around tearing down statues
that uh not even like they tore down a
statue of Hans Christian Hagg who was an
abolitionist who died fighting to free
slaves
so okay I guess whatever I don't know
what they're but if if they're all about
this then I I think they'd agree with us
right we can you know get antifa get on
board with this bill and we'll get rid
of the democratic party this is such a
power play I love it because then the
Democrats will have to say no no like I
want to see how many other states
another state legislators pick it up and
get some momentum gotta make some phone
calls to West Virginia yeah seriously
yeah we'll talk to uh we're gonna be I
think the plan is to be at Congress
again this Friday big old congress party
yeah I'm not going to say too much but I
think we're gonna be there I'll I'll
make sure to bring this up to all of
them like hey you guys want to do the
condemning slavery act or something like
that and then it's to publicly denounce
and reject any political party that's
ever supported slavery we'll start
making picket signs as soon as the
show's over yeah I'm excited yeah it's
the ultimate cancel act so it's perfect
yeah the ultimate new magic coming out
against this act
I think we're okay okay what they'll try
and do is amend it to be like
recognizing the fears of America Act or
something like that and then what
they'll do is they'll be like it's not
the Democratic party it's all America
and the Republicans have to counter and
be like actually we're the ones who
wanted to get rid of the slavery so you
know sorry remember that whole War thing
yeah that was you guys and you know uh
just trying to change your name doesn't
doesn't change anything not only that
but like people always rag on The Young
Turks because their name is like The
Young Turks which was a genocidal group
of people and you know it's like imagine
naming your media organization the
Hitler Youth is basically what The Young
Turks did but like think about the
Democratic party then like the
Democratic party is the organization
that that represented slavers and
slavery if you're going to be critical
of The Young Turks that you certainly
got to be critical of of the democratic
party title right yeah fine with me and
they can't really like pull a Washington
Redskins slash what are the commanders
now like it's not like they can be like
well now we're the and their masks now
we're the Confederates
I love that the mascot for the
Washington commanders is a pig yeah it's
terrible
terrible of this you guys not unders
like wow oh there's someone is either
super ironic or they just missed it
completely there's there is a Savvy meme
Lord who worked for that company it was
like this is going to be the greatest
thing this is the most hilarious thing
yeah apparently there's uh there's
something about there were players that
were called the hogs in the 80s the
offensive line or something like that
and so that's how the the pigs are
associated with the uh Washington it's a
stretch it's a big stretch and you'd
think that someone would be like oh why
do we want to go ahead and call the
Washington team you know with the seat
of power is and at least be like a horse
right that's like what Commander's rode
during the war
like I
I like you can't like file papers in
these companies these big companies
without there being oversight and I know
that there's a video out there of some
board member or some like employee
that's in the corner like filming the
discussion they had and I need to see it
I love it I just can't imagine I feel
like the best part of this bill is that
it's here the sad part is that I don't
think that it will survive like
unfortunately I don't think it'll pass
if it does I'd be happy to be wrong on
this one I think sometimes one of the
coolest things about State Legislature
is state legislators is that they just
introduce things to prove a point right
they say like even though I know this
won't make it out of committee I think
that we should talk about the fact that
we haven't condemned this Congress
passed the Congress passed the
anti-lynching bill like just last year
and that is literally just for show yeah
just to you know prove a point so it's
not just at State decades after they
probably should have right yeah it
wasn't anything I mean with State I
think it's more interesting because then
you have the conversation right like if
even if Florida doesn't pass this we all
recognize that perhaps we should condemn
parties that had slaveries as part of
their platform
yeah we should provide funding to
parties that oppose it
guaranteed the green party is like here
we go I'm ready well I don't know when
is the Green Party founded I don't think
they've been around post slavery so
they've never had it in their platform
that's fair point Democrats are just in
trouble they're uh they're a relic of a
bygone era Libertarians are excited yeah
yeah they've been around for a long time
right they've been around since the 70s
and they have always been opposed to
slavery oh yes keep confidently say that
I can very confidently can't say it if
you're a Democrat the libertarian party
has always been opposed to slavery they
should uh make the bill the um rejecting
political parties that support slavery
and supporting political parties that
don't act yeah and just being like that
leaves you Democrats green party you're
all right Republicans Libertarians
Reform Party man look at this huge list
of Working Families party they're good
Democrats no you're on the No-No list
the Tea Party will rise again yeah here
they come it would be kind of
interesting though if like there
couldn't be a Democratic party would
they just Rebrand Allah
whoever or would you get enough like
people bleeding out to have different
different factions of the party they
would quickly consolidate around a
person that has decided what the new
party probably Barack Obama
it would be like someone someone like
Barack Obama that would say okay you're
on the Hakeem Jeffries is like yes we
can do to destroy this party so I can
rise to the top I don't think that it'll
even get to the point where a pat where
it would pass in the U.S but I but I I
imagine the circumstances would be they
would they would coalesce around a
person that comes up with a name for the
new party and and they would you know
reluctantly leave the Democrat the DNC
but all the same people would go over
because you're not getting rid of any
ideas you're just getting rid of a name
I suppose in the longer run if you can
if you can suppress ideas then you will
eventually eliminate them from the from
the psyche from the population and
that's the purpose of all the censorship
they're engaging in that's that's the
idea I think that the the whole
um if you don't have the words to uh
articulate a thought then you can't
think the wrong things I'd like the the
whole 1984 justification for Newspeak
that is something that's legit in
practice nowadays the reason that the
lgbtq uh political Lobby demands that
you uh say that a trans woman is a woman
is because they're demanding that you
conceptualize a trans woman and a
biologic woman as the same they're
making a demand on your cognitive
Liberty and they're they're doing it by
messing with the the language that we
use with the meanings of words right
this is what they did on the last
Twitter board or the last Twitter
um you know people they they were
Banning the word groomer to call out
predatory adults who were grooming
children and if you ban the words then
like you said you're Banning their their
cognitive ability to make assumptions
and uh accurately assess people's
behavior
yeah so it kind of feels like
everything's falling apart a little bit
you know but uh it's okay because we
have chickens they're out doing their
thing and they give us eggs and one of
the chickens is brooding uh one of the
silkies so what we do now is we're going
to take a bunch of eggs from all the
different chickens and put them
underneath the Broody silky which will
then hatch a variety like like a a a
plethora of chicken varieties so when uh
it all comes crashing down and you find
yourself in a city fighting Agnes over
the last can of beans in the in front of
the bodega I'm gonna be sitting there
with Roberto Jr enjoying some fresh
scrambled eggs see I don't mind some
turbulence right like I think having
these issues in front of us makes us
talk about them I think that was one of
the mistakes that some conservatives had
for a while which is to say Live and Let
Live which I agree with for the most
part but you can also say I disagree I
don't believe in that and I think for so
long sort of out of politeness we were
saying like oh just everyone will just
keep to themselves and we won't address
things and then you get to the point
where it gets so out of control that
you're asked like do you think it's okay
for a teacher to tell a child that
they're transgender and then not tell
the parents like we have to be willing
to have the hard conversations and
especially if they're if the uh the
opposition to these two two hard ideas
says basically well to avoid that we'll
take down monuments and we'll we'll edit
books and we'll change things so that we
can just avoid these conversations it
makes us a weaker Society if we can't
deal with this kind of uh disagreement I
think that this speaks to the to
um
Matt Walsh's point and and to Tim's
point when he says that uh we need to be
mean
um I don't think that
maybe mean isn't the the best word but
uh
pulling back from being
Frank when we describe things uh it's
it's detrimental to the two people's
ability to understand what we're talking
about yeah you got to push it more than
you normally would I guess you don't you
if you've you've given up ground to
progressives we've given up so so much
ground that now taught that now children
are literally being targeted for
ideological you know
um
you unplugged the UFO oh no it's okay I
took out the UFO when I sit on that side
table Yeah but there's also an an
empathy a true empathy for calling
things the way they are there's no
niceness about calling you know these
body positive people healthy when it's
not there's no positivity and there's no
empathy in saying that these trans
people that are mutilating themselves
are healthy because that is not leading
them down fulfilled lives that is
destroying them and that's also the
importance of we need to build our own
things if we're going to actually combat
the woke left we can't just be reacting
to them and we can't just be tearing
them down there is an importance to it
because they have left and they've
planted seeds and they have gone down
and they have strong roots but we also
need to plant our own seeds like I said
if we want to combat this body body
positivity movement you need to go to
the gym right if we want to combat the
taking down of statues we need to make
our own if we want to combat the woke
left's gender ideology we need to make
our own schools we need to homeschool
and if we want to combat the end of the
world then we gotta make our own chicken
coops right Tim thanks for watching this
clip from from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time